[Musik]
giulia steingruber als schweizer fahnen
trägerin und dahinter unser team und da
sind sie und wir genießen jede sekunde
und fast keiner hatte sich nehmen lassen
hier bei der eröffnungsfeier einzulaufen
eindrücke für die genau weiß dass ich
werde der wisent ist geschafft
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich noch ein noch ein
rücktritt overaths immerhin ist es nicht
weil die tabelle machen
dafür kannst so fest das ist ja das ist
noch mal schaffe das sieht ja dass sie
vor dem olympia-start leidet sie noch
recht rechten ist auch geld nach dem
rücktritt zurückzukaufen gar nicht das
richtige wissen was sie eigentlich noch
sturm morgen wieder da mit herz bewegt
hat immer sexy sexy und er wäre der
schnitt so dass immer nur bewachen
ich weiß einfach dass es der war aus
ihren lukas fischer galt zumindest in
der schweiz als ausnahmetalent im
kunstturnen seine silbermedaille am
barren bei der europameisterschaft vor
drei jahren in moskau aber auch seine
emotionale art mit rückschlägen durch
operationen und besonders durch seine
krankheit epilepsie umzugehen machten
ihn zum liebling der medien
seinen letzten großen auftritt hatte er
ein jahr vor den olympischen spielen in
rio
der rücktritt mit gerade mal 25 weil
eine erneute operation drohte
[Musik]
jetzt wahlkampf dann alle energie in die
wiederum vorgeschickt um ist große ziel
stellen bis spiel in rio zu erreichen
ohne dass sie haben ihr körper zeigt man
jetzt sein werk und dass man sie richtig
ich schau beruf und war für mich ein
neues und spannendes leben der andere
weniger wochen
[Applaus]
seit seinem rücktritt wohnt lukas wieder
auf 16 quadratmetern zu hause bei seinen
eltern in möriken auch sie haben für ge
turms und den kleinen lukas mit in die
halle genommen
seine karriere beginnt bereits mit vier
jahren
[Musik]
ja dass ich die grünen ja gerade
fraglich ob in 2010
ja und dann gefangen wird das alte
schulhaus personensuche ja ich bin im
weg sie haben mich wieso die haut passt
ideal zu ähnlichen speziell sehr
emotionale musik week und blut und
nachfrage eingestellt und habe mich
selber zurückzog und sämtliche von ihr
habt mich als person gar nix geklappt
und dan ist denn zog sie das hier zur
musik und im august in epilepsy
überholen
ja und ich sage nicht nur schlecht für
mich
denke mal wieder angefangen mich selber
finde mich die persönlichkeit das
glauben wie der mini mini persönlichkeit
zurückziehen will
wichtig sich william christie ich glaub
ich sie im laufe und dani und die harnik
eine epilepsie h und irgendwie anders
sie eigentlich b ja das hat mir einfach
so zurück zurück kommt zu mir selber und
ich habe mir ist egal was andere
gedankenkraft singen ist und ich glück
was ist da oder der oder die seite für
mich was ich die ganze zeit gemacht habe
schätzte volk aus
was die andere über mich gesagt
ich kenne lukas unterdessen seit zwei
jahren und habe viele höhen und tiefen
miterlebt ist seine karriere auch ohne
olympische spiele ein erfolg des mini
karriere stolz
mit alldem wo mich und mich eigentlich
hat trainer andre witters machen wie
tesco ich werde den punkt lang zu nicht
sagen ich bin stolz dass sie gleich und
hätte ich nicht sagen es hat ja noch ein
msi es hat hier noch eine besser sieht
natürlich es hat ja und noch viel mehr
möglich sie aber das ist so und in
zweiter ein paar vize europameister nach
all dem sei halt eine schwere sache und
eine steigung rewag leitwort sind ich
hoffe ihr alle wie überwunden und kann
mir niemals dank dass ich das schaffe
vermitteln
ich habe immer daran geglaubt dass es
ohne große ziel erreichen und denn es
passiert und ich bin froh
angeschafft auch heute noch dominiert
das tägliche training seinen alltag wohl
auch eines lukas struktur gibt
vielleicht auch ein stück geborgenheit
seiner welt die erkennt
[Musik]
macht also sofort entschlossen zum - die
jungs passt dann ist das gemacht habe
[Musik]
ja schon recht heftig sie also meine
hand der früher zum teil sogar drei
trainings kapital von frühstück ein haus
zwischen und nachher frühstück den
morgen trennen setzten drischt und und
den mittagspausen nach einer madryn
street ist so was ich auch anrechte
tannin knappe woche juni und ist machen
also ich trainiere jeden tag am meer die
ganztags in italien machen vermittler
bis über mittag und jogger noch morgen
schaffen werde ich bin für mehr
schlachten wenn die ganz okay
[Musik]
er ist noch so unterstützung vom verband
über vor jetzt dann auch irgendwann
schließen
ich bin ja noch ein abschlussgespräch
bis ende monat eine woche nach
ja ich im nachhinein wenigsten darüber
nachdenkt ist einfach so dass sich
wünscht dass sie erhalten die hand vor
augen hat coop athletisches leben
zurückzufinden will die stadt vor
[Musik]
eigentlich also ich bin ja das ist schon
brutal zu aber ich mache verband
überhaupt schon vor der fabrik fans
einfach schön wenn man ein bisschen
machen
es gibt nichts wofür ich weniger mir
hand als sie heute aber das ist halt
individuellen aber handbuch wurde mir
gesagt ich finde es einfach schön ich
liebe wird kriegt chance
und ja nicht nur nicht nur riesig darauf
da bezahlt dass man dass man die tour
unterstützung gebrochen sondern auch
psychisch physisch wie wie kann ich mit
dem und plötzlich nämlich das trainieren
wir das geschafft haben die gar nicht
mit dem plötzlich als normaler mensch zu
sein
franke ist plötzlich so viel wie offen
sie sind die kategorie kata oder
religion
es ist wie zu viel auf eine spezielle
ton bronze ging mit 20 jahren 21 uhr
nochmals klopp ja was mach ich jetzt
[Musik]
ich frage nach dem sportpsychologen
daniel briere vom bundesamt für sport in
magglingen
auch er hat lukas während seiner aktiven
zeit betreute natürlich eine schwierige
position bayerische hätten die krankheit
immer wieder rückschläge ihnen
verletzungen rückschläge und um schloss
sich im prinzip aus bariton erneut scsi
und ist das natürlich auch nötige
marketing exeo und exeo spitzenteams
und dass er die situation natürlich
erschwert und den ich das relativ
schnell passiert dass ihre kindheit und
die das im headquarter wenig
vorbereitungszeit
also mich im kino wenig können
unterstützung war das relativ schnell
versteht gemacht und den wall cracked es
noch zeit für den sprung von der alten
in die neue welt seit zwei jahren ist
lukas mit der alleinerziehenden mutter
marina zusammen
die zeit nach seinem rücktritt war auch
für sie hart
ja es ist schwierig sie mit ein wenig
hilfe und nichts ist wahr machen sagt
ortslandwirt tobisch ich mich so hilflos
gefühlt und das neue ziel gestartet das
raumfeld rucksack und dann jedoch dass
die sohlen durch einen aufstand
es ist wie schwierig sie zum abschätzen
was braucht etwas was machen sie was ihr
habt also was es braucht
[Musik]
ausgezahlt hat sich die karriere nicht
gerade mal 1500 franken plus miete für
ein zimmer in einer wg hat er nach
seiner ausbildung beim schweizer
turnverband im monat verdient seine
ersparnisse investiert lukas seit dem
rücktritt in sein neues projekt ein
bühnenprogramm aus tanz sport und musik
[Musik]
meine show besteht aus verschiedenen
jüngst das ist schon faszinierend finde
ich die verschiedenen kunstformen zu
verbinden
sie ist nicht wie viel ich viel glaubitz
der waren oder hauptbestandteil ist ich
wirklich aus kirche ganz emotionen pur
akrobatik comedy mit akrobatik gemischt
und denn wirklich verzichtbare und wird
ständig sagen das ganze umrahmt und noch
spezielle macht man einfach das ganze
entwickelt und karriere
es ist nicht nur der barren aber eben
doch sehr viel davon und anspruchsvoll
vielleicht weil lukas seinem publikum
und vor allem sich selbst beweisen
möchte dass seine karriere auf großer
bühne eben doch nicht ganz vorbei ist
finanziell ist es ein akt ohne netz und
doppelten boden nur wenn die show vom
publikum angenommen wird kann er damit
geld verdienen
das gilt auch für seine musik um seine
rückschläge zu verarbeiten hat der vor
drei jahren angefangen zu singen wird
professionelle aufnahmen hat er sogar
ein studio gebucht
[Musik]
mai
die zukunft die chance die eigene musik
per somit das badener lied run
besprechen und retten also auf der piste
und peter bender und hat schon extrem
viel text ich schreibe frauen noch ein
rücktritt ist los war irgendwie ihr und
gerade quests wir nach einer forscherin
überschrieben und das sind so extrem die
tiefgründige texte - also und mich ganz
herbst den faktor 1000 ist und er hat
halt wie im zustand sprechen
monitore
[Musik]
stimmungen neuigkeiten und erfolge auf
seinem weg ins neue leben teilt lukas
mit seiner fangemeinde in den sozialen
netzwerken
[Musik]
und fraglos
rott lied what i oder der post kann
textilkette romanik gleichstand und ich
bezahle ich lade es geht immer es geht
immer einige womit sie gleicht aber gar
nicht auf - sie sind und da geht aber
dass superstars verloren ist instagram
musik 800 und apple und facebook
mittlerweile über physik also die letzte
kraft abgang wirkung seine fangemeinde
in der virtuellen welt auch für die
realität zu aktivieren gelingt die noch
nicht da wird der auftritt mit seiner
show in kreuzlingen zeigt wie weit der
weg für eine erfolgreiche karriere noch
ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
von der showbühne an einen normalen
arbeitsplatz
seit drei wochen arbeitet lukas b r
assistent in der automobilbranche
zunächst mal für ein jahr auf 40 prozent
basis
[Musik]
du als sportler leistung immer das ziel
ganz speziellen gab es hier im job es
ist ich merke was ich heute als super
gut machen und und grad möglich stören
die hilfe und das ziel ist immer das sie
arbeitet sehr gut
heutige am ende folgte und dass das auch
alle zufrieden sind mit tempo nicht
leisten kann sich auch vorstellen dass
es ist irgendwann mal 100 prozent job
ist und du musik und sport das ist nur
noch so zum vergnügen macht und gar
nicht mehr so das ziel ist okay das ist
mein job
ich mag keine weniger also das ist immer
das wetter gute sache und sind ich mache
gern und osram er warte aber nie
geschafft kann jetzt entwickeln und
verwirklichen
xanthone und ja das wäre
und ich würde am liebsten schon in dem
segment fuß fassen
ich wünsche ihnen sehr dass es gelingt
aber tatsächlich eine chance hat kann
ich nicht beurteilen
das aber wirklich alles dafür tut davon
bin ich nicht nur überzeugt das weiß ich
jetzt
[Musik]